the names he fencin is of reference to a
Nick Cave song where he says and Dylan
Thomas died drunk at st. Vincent's
Hospital I was like uh sounds about
right surgeon surgeon is a song I wrote
that references Marilyn Monroe's diary
in it she was talking about Lee
Strasberg her acting coach she wrote
best finest surgeon Lee Strasberg
come cut me open wow that's great the
solo at the end is not a guitar it's um
it's a synth played by my friend Bobby
sparks and he just like ripped that solo
and then live I learned the solo and I
would play a variation of it every night
during the making of the cruel music
video I was buried up to here in dirt
and then there were these massive walls
that were covered in dirt and trees and
all this stuff but I had to be on a
pulley and a lever system so they were
these giant walls of mud and trees like
three sided box and then another piece
here that was also covered in dirt and
all that and then it had a little cutout
for where my head would go at at the end
of the chute the special-effects makeup
girl asked if she could take the walls
home I was like well I'm still I'm so
curious to know what she did with those
walls
I think they smelled like cow manure
[Music]
New York the song New York is I took the
inspiration from when I was just walking
around my East Village neighborhood you
know you live so much life in New York
and you live so much like life and like
these very small blocks and this like
kind of routes that you take every day I
was thinking those things and I was
thinking about a friend who had moved
out of New York and had had moved away
and I just texted him like New York
isn't new yet
New York without you and then I was like
huh hmm no squirrel that away for for a
song and that was the kind of genesis of
it you grow so much when you think about
who you've been in this tiny amount of
amount of space it's sweet you're living
with the ghosts of yourself and of all
your heroes smoking suction real pop
bang or that one I started writing
smoking section on a ferry from Sweden
to Poland
now who goes from Sweden to Poland do
you think not people vacationing I could
assure you that but it was all like
truckers like kind of burly polish
truckers on this cruise I was kind of
walking around I saw oh they have a spa
great I'll you know I could use a
massage and so I go in and it was
clearly like not like a traditional
massage parlor I think that it was more
like for the truckers you know what I'm
saying I came in completely oblivious
and this woman just proceeded to like
look at me kind of confoundedly and then
pinched me for about 30 minutes just
like this kind of like like okay this is
very bizarre experience so I was like
well I guess I'm gonna go hide in my
room and avoid the sort of like leering
of increasingly drunk truckers so I
started writing those lyrics which are
deeply sad loss ageless they call Las
Vegas like lost wages I think or maybe
there's a suit in a Steely Dan song but
loss ageless looked right to me and felt
like it captured a certain aspect of
this city the Peter Pan quality I think
that like a lot of people who live here
have and certainly like a fear of
getting older a fear of decay for that
that song for me I was always just
picturing like a wave that kept building
and building and building and just never
broke and like the kind of people like
salty kind of characters you meet the
person who never wrote that memoir but
wants to tell you all about it just
broken dreams and decay but it's a love
song my aunt and uncle allure jazz to a
call took and Patty they're wonderful
and I had them come down to my studio
and just play around for a few days and
I had my aunt singing on the how good
honey boy Yahoo she does a great line
there and my uncle's just kind of
riffing
all over it's very cool no no I mean my
sisters like to sing and we would like
go on car trips and my mom and my
sisters and I would all sing and
harmonize but nobody like did it past
kind of casual or choir in school I
learned all kinds of things technical
and esoteric they played me John
Coltrane's Love supreme for the first
time I mean
I wouldn't I wouldn't be doing what I'm
doing if they hadn't truly showed me how
and kicked my ass frankly pills Cara is
singing the pills line choosing the
pills to make pills to sleep yeah I did
it like a very posh British voice I
tried my friend Kate who's Welsh and
that was really nice but a little too
serious and then car ended up singing it
and it was great it doesn't remind me of
the real Slim Shady but I love that song
and I love the kind of Willy Wonka land
aspect of it and it's it's nice to kind
of have this like Nursery Rhyme feeling
and on top of it you're saying some like
really dark [ __ ] like I need help that
that I I was kind of like definitely
going back to old Eminem and I was
thinking about that song he's great he's
such a great dude yeah we've done we've
done a couple things I he kind of came
over before they had finished Kendricks
damn and and I was just like you know
playing a bunch of guitar riffs and we
were just kind of vibing and seeing if
anything was was interesting and then I
heard don't humble and I was like I got
so excited and I thought maybe that's my
guitar and I texted him he was like no
sorry that was our tech Brian I was like
damn it
damn it so close hang on me
[Music]
hang on me was a song that on mass
seduction I kind of couldn't figure out
what sonic space it was supposed to live
in there was something that felt endemic
about that we do do do do do do do do do
it like that it could be a big like rock
kind of song but it just never like I
tried to kind of cram it in that space
and it just was like nah no sorry so
that wouldn't ended up being small and
an intimate on on mass seduction and
then same with on the piano album
everything on the piano album just gets
like 45% sadder it's been so long
working on the songs for mass seduction
and I just wanted to to get to live in
them in a way that had nothing to do
with my guitar had nothing to do with
production or anything and just just
like seeing them and play them live it
was like it was a way of like closing
the chapter for me on mass seduction was
was
solidifying them in this really sweet
and small way happy birthday Johnny
[Music]
is it 23 there's like a Johnny trilogy
at this point because there's the Mary
me John on my first record and then
there's a prince Johnny on the st.
Vincent self-titled one and then there's
happy birthday Johnny on on this one the
song is you know I think everybody has
liked that person they simultaneously
like just completely fill you with joy
and then also completely break your
heart and in so many ways and that's the
Johnny character from he's like loveable
troubled like lost soul Savior that I
wrote when I was 16 I was listening to a
lot of as I listened to Billie Holiday
and I had a little karaoke kind of
machine and I would just practice her
licks and her runs that was that melody
was kind of born of trying to follow
along - Billie the song had tension and
it needed release and I was like oh yeah
what about please from you know X number
of years ago and it just fit perfectly
into the narrative and and was the
release that the universes and fries
needed slow disco
[Music]
the first version of slow disco was the
kind of pretty string version that's on
the mass seduction record and then I
recorded the soft pretty version on the
piano record oddly enough it was Taylor
Swift who works with Jack Antonoff all
the time and said like Jack please
you guys got to make a pop version of
that song so we did and it yeah because
I always felt like that song it could
just wear a lot of different suits and
still be solid so we did three versions
of it very postmodern look out Kanye I'm
really proud of the color palette on
this song called the bed it was not a
top-ten hit make sure you it's probably
one of the darkest in my in my catalog
but I'm really proud of the composition
it's really like pastel and pretty I
think that was the most like Debussy I
ever went not comparing myself to WC I
mean just some of the colors are nice
and lawyer I start anywhere I can
sometimes it's a lyric you know song
like happy birthday Johnny was that was
just a like a short story pretty much it
didn't have a melody at first and other
songs come from really technical ways
like you know converting a bunch of MIDI
notes and tweaking them and then running
them through synths and then you know
kind of going like what would Skinny
Puppy do or what you know it's like
there's a lot of ways to get in to get
into song and then sometimes it's
melodies I I guess I sing in my sleep
and so I'll wake up with melodies in my
head and just record them really quickly
and then go back through and some they
just suggest words and they you just
kind of put it all together really
you're just looking for a thread